ROMAN NURIK: Hello and welcome
to Android Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
My name's Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And,
hi, I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today, in
our special episode of Android
Design in Action-- I feel like I
say special episode every week,
but--
ADAM KOCH: That's because it is
a special episode every week.
ROMAN NURIK: --yeah, I guess.
But this week, it's actually
a very special episode.
We're going to be
talking about what's
new in Android 4.4 KitKat, which
was just recently announced.
We're going to talk through
a couple of specific changes,
a couple of new design
guidelines, updates
that all designers
should be aware of when
planning for Android 4.4 KitKat.
So, without further ado,
let's jump into the content.
So the very first thing we
should probably talk about
is the new Nexus 5.
As with every platform
release for Android,
there's usually a lead device,
as we call it, I guess,
that comes out.
And it's kind of the showcase
device for that platform
release.
I think for Android 4.2,
it was the-- what was it,
the Nexus 4 or the Nexus
10-- I forget already.
And then for Android 4.3, it
was the Nexus 7, 2013 edition.
But anyway, so for Android
4.4, it's the Nexus 5.
And the Nexus 5, as
you might imagine,
is about a five inch device.
I think it's like something
like 4.95 inches diagonally.
But here's some of the
interesting characteristics
that you don't really get from
the spec sheet, if you will.
These are
characteristics that are
very important for designers.
So the first is that it's
5 inches, so it's a phone.
It's very obviously a phone,
not really a tablet at all.
But next, I think is a
very important point here,
is the screen resolution in
density-independent pixels.
So, as most of you know,
anytime you're designing layouts
or things like that,
you should really
be thinking in terms of
density-independent pixels,
rather than just
regular pixel units,
because that more
accurately represents
the size of the device,
which is very important,
obviously, for layout purposes.
So the screen size of the
Nexus 5 is 640 by 360 dp.
And that's actually
the same exact screen
size in dp as the Galaxy Nexus.
It's a little more
narrow than the Nexus 4,
but that's kind of
the screen size there.
And then the last
bit of information
here is the logical
density of the device.
Now the screen itself is
about 440 points per inch,
or dots per inch.
But the logical density,
as you guys probably know,
we actually use density buckets.
The logical density of the
device is XXHDPI, or 480 dpi.
So, if you're
creating assets now,
if you're creating
assets for your apps,
you should definitely
start thinking about--
and actually, if you haven't
already been thinking about it
because of other devices like
the Galaxy S4, or the HTC One,
you should definitely start
thinking about XXHDPI,
as the highest density assets.
So before we move on,
anything else you guys
want to say about the Nexus 5?
ADAM KOCH: Nope, not really.
It's a great device.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, the
screen is incredibly crisp.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
it's pretty amazing.
Reading text on
the screen is just
a really, really
great experience.
It's beautiful.
Here's the Nexus.
We have a couple of Nexus
5's, but here it is.
I'm sure you guys will see in
stores and all that, whatever.
Anyway, let's move
on to branding.
Nick, do you want to
talk about branding?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
So one of the
changes in KitKat is
we've really tried
to move the system
UI into a more kind
of neutral tone.
So what I mean by that is in
prior releases of Android,
we often used a very kind of
strong blue accent color, which
you might have seen
in the status bar
where the notification
icons go-- so the signal
strength, and battery,
and so forth--
as well as the default kind
of pressed state color.
Whenever you touch on any
item, or radio button,
check boxes, and so
forth, they would
have this very
high contrast blue.
So the problem with that
was that it could very well
clash with the branding
and the coloring
which you were trying to bring
to your app's personality.
So in Android 4.4, we've really
toned back this color palette
that the OS uses in order to
let the applications stand out
and show their
own personalities.
So the OS really
does get out the way
and doesn't impose
its own personality
within your application.
And so you'll see this
throughout the application
in the notification
icon scheme, changing
to this muted gray and
white color, as well as
the change in the default
touch highlight states.
So, as before, the
idea of this is really
to allow you to bring your
own personality to the app.
So as we've called
out here on the slide,
there's some tools
out there, such
as android.holo-colors.com,
which will help you to marry
the Holo digital theme, the
look and feel of the buttons
and check boxes and so forth,
with your own brand accent
colors.
ROMAN NURIK: I'm having trouble
zooming for some reason.
But one of the things that
we should probably mention
is that there's a new section
in the design guide called
the Your Branding section.
I think it's under
/design/style.
And it calls out
specifically things
that you should keep in mind.
For example, using your
brand accent colors
rather than using
the default Holo blue
everywhere-- use your
brand accent colors.
One thing, I guess, that
is important to note here
is that this has been
around for awhile.
The guidance has
always been to try
to customize, to try to kind of
find the right balance visually
between your brand and Holo.
And color is one of the best
ways to introduce your brand.
So now we're just
formalizing that
in the design guide in
this Your Branding section.
So there's two examples
here, I think, in the guide.
The first is Google Wallet,
using the Google blue,
red, yellow, and green
colors throughout the UI
to add some flourishes, as
well as the Google Play Music
example, which was a very
good example of branding,
where you see orange
basically everywhere replacing
stock blue.
So as part of this new
Your Branding section,
at the very bottom, you'll also
notice the section on icons.
And specifically, it talks
about the distinction
between visual styling
and iconography,
I guess the actual glyphs,
or the meanings of the icons.
So basically, just to
summarize this point-- here
at the bottom, it
basically says when
you're coming from
other platforms,
or when you have an existing
visual style for your icons,
make sure that if there's
something in the Android icon
pallet that is universal--
for example, Sharing,
or Refresh, or things like
that-- make sure that you apply
your visual style to
Android's iconography.
So use the object or the actual
icon from Android's palette,
but apply your visual styling.
So here's an example.
So let's say you have
these three icons,
and you have Upload,
View on Web, and Share.
So iOS7 recently introduced
this new visual styling
for that platform
where they basically
have outlines as
the primary motif,
right, throughout--
each icon, everything
is basically just an outline.
So here are some of the icons
you may build for, say, iOS7.
And they have a new Share icon.
It looks like this.
But when you're taking
this to Android,
make sure that you don't just
blindly copy those same icons.
That you apply-- whatever visual
styling you deem necessary
for your app, or you
deem fit for your app,
let's say in this case again,
outlines, but still use
Android's actual icons.
So here's the
Android Share icon.
This is just the example
of the Android Share
icon with the outline
motif applied.
So this section of the Your
Branding Design Guide pattern,
or Style section, really
just formalizes that.
Just make sure that
you are applying this,
you're not just blindly
copying the exact PNG assets
across platforms.
And if your styling, if your
visual style is not outlines,
if it's something
else-- if it involves,
you know, 3D effects or
whatever, if that's your thing,
then that's fine as long as you
maintain Android's iconography.
All right, so let's move on.
Actually, real quick, just
to drive the point home--
so you wouldn't use
something like the top right
here on Android
for sharing, you'd
use something like
the bottom right here.
Moving on, touch feedback--
ADAM KOCH: So in
Android 4.4 KitKat,
I think as Nick mentioned
before, touch feedback has more
of a neutral color
applied to it.
So when you look at
the system UI widgets,
you'll notice now that there's
this much more neutral color,
as opposed to this Holo blue
that you've become used to.
So in this particular
case, we see a button,
the standard Android
widget for a button.
And there's a 10% opaque black
overlay applied accordingly.
And when it comes to
implementing your own touch
feedback, you should
follow a similar guideline,
so you should have a more
subtle and neutral color tone.
And, of course, if you're
adapting for your brand,
and you have a color
that matches your brand,
you could also apply that when
creating your touch feedback.
We talked about touch feedback
on images the other week,
and the same kind
of applies there.
You can also go with the
more neutral, 10% opaque
black overlay, or you can apply
your brand colors accordingly.
ROMAN NURIK: So
basically, anytime
you have touch
feedback in your app,
try avoid the
stock default blue.
And actually, the default
blue, for developers out there,
if you just use selectable
item background,
that is no longer blue.
It's actually kind of like a
light grey at about 10% or 20%
opacity.
But the idea is that it
should be more subtle.
And anytime you have touch
feedback, or basically
any widget in your
app, make sure
that it's not using
the stock blue,
unless blue is your
brand accent color.
Make sure that it's either
something very neutral,
like a gray scale tone
or something like that,
or your brand accent setting
and stuff, main thing there.
Moving on to full
screen-- so this
is actually a new guideline.
It's under
developer.android.com/design/patterns,
and this guideline talks about
when and how you should present
full screen UIs to your users.
So there's two
modes, two, I guess,
approaches that they
talk about, and they're
called Lean Back and Immersive.
So Lean Back, you guys
have already seen before.
If you open up YouTube and
you start playing a video,
the system UI-- the navigation
bar, the thing with Back, Home,
and Recent-- and the status
bar, the thing with your status
icons, and your clock, and
all that, those fade away.
And the full screen
is left for the video.
It's a truly immersive
video playback UI.
Now, as soon as you
touch the screen,
the navigation bar-- the thing
with Back, Home, and Recent--
and the status bar fade in.
Now this is called Lean
Back because, generally,
if you're watching a
video, you're not really
interacting with
the screen, right.
You're not doing stuff in
the middle of the screen.
You're just sitting back
and watching the video.
And so as soon as you touch
the screen, the bars appear.
That basically prevents the
app from doing anything else
with the screen.
Now, I guess using the or--
ADAM KOCH: Interacting
with the screen.
ROMAN NURIK: --yes, exactly.
With Immersive mode--
this is something
that's new in
Android 4.4 KitKat.
And Immersive mode basically,
again, hides the bars,
but it also allows
the user to interact
with the middle of the screen.
And Immersive mode is more
suitable for things like games,
where you actually need to
interact with the screen,
or book readers, where you're
kind of flipping between pages.
Now the reason that
the Lean Back mode--
as soon as you
touch the screen it
shows the bars--
the reason for that
is really because those
bars are critical.
You know, not having
access, or losing access
to Back, Home, or Recent,
it can fundamentally
break your experience or
your usage of the device.
And so that's why it
consumes that first touch
and shows them automatically.
In Immersive mode, the way in
which a user can show the bars
is by swiping down from
the top of the screen,
or swiping up from the
bottom of the screen.
And every time--
actually, I guess
we'll look at this in a
second-- anytime you hide
the bars in Immersive mode,
you basically see this.
Actually no, not any time--
the first time in a single,
in a specific app,
that you hide the bars,
they'll see this pop-up
overlay type thing.
And it'll basically
say swipe down
from the top of the screen to
show access to your Back, Home,
and Recents, and
stuff like that.
So as soon as you
swipe down, you'll
actually see your bars again.
But the idea is that now,
in this Immersive mode,
you can use touch events
and everything, all
in the middle of the screen,
without showing the Back, Home,
and Recent.
And it's really, really ideal
for things like book readers
and games and things like that.
So we have a full-- we're not
going to talk in too much more
detail on this--
NICK BUTCHER: We could demo it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I
guess we could demo it.
So--
NICK BUTCHER: Sign us out.
ROMAN NURIK: --we could swipe.
That's not actually
going to work
because I think we're in a
special mode in our Nexus 10.
But the point here is that we
have-- so this is a new mode.
It's called Immersive mode.
We're going to have a DevByte
released on this very shortly.
And the DevByte
is basically going
to explain how you
actually use these APIs.
It's actually very, very simple.
It's not a very
complicated API to use,
but it's very, very powerful.
So, long story short, if you're
building a game, or a book
reader, or a magazine
reader, anything like that,
make sure to check out
Immersive mode in KitKat.
NICK BUTCHER: And
you have full control
of exiting Immersive
mode as well.
While the system provides
those gestures, the swipe up
from the bottom or
down from the top,
but you can also control that.
So, for example, Play Books
takes over every single pixel,
so when you're reading, you
get this fully immersive mode.
But if you tap a gesture
which they always
use to show the system Chrome,
so the action bar comes back
and the text controls come back.
But they've also
listened to that's
happened and restored
the system UI as well.
So you have full
control over this.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
All right, let's move on.
Translucent bars-- is that Nick?
Nick, you want to talk
about translucent bars?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
So a slight variation upon
this theme is translucent bars.
So this is still showing
the system Chromes
as showing the status bar
and the navigation bar
at the bottom, but
allowing your application
to draw to that same real
estate with minimal background
protection applied over the top.
So this is used to great
effect by the new home screen,
the new launcher
application on the Nexus 5,
which allows you to
show the wallpaper,
like from edge to edge at the
screen, while still preserving
those system functions.
And your application
can do the same thing.
So if we go on to the next
slide to take a look at a sample
application of the kind
of thing you could build.
So here's an
application which is
using Maps as the
main UI element.
And here you can see that
we're extending the content
all the way behind
the system bars.
So it really gives you
this immersive feel,
that the map is the entirety of
the canvas you're drawing to,
and you just have this minimal
background protection applied.
And you can control what is
drawn behind the system bars.
ROMAN NURIK: So two points I
wanted to make [INAUDIBLE],
go ahead.
NICK BUTCHER: I was going to
say, as a slight-- not new
in Android 4.4, but in a very
recent update to the Google
Play Services Library,
you now have the ability
to do more with Maps, have
a little bit more control
over the stock UI Maps Chrome.
So that's things
like here, we can
see the Locate Me, and the
Zoom In and Out button, as well
as the orientation
compass point.
You can now set padding
on those controls
so that if you do have system
UIs, such as the action
bar at the top, and the
system bar, and buttons
at the bottom, or even your own
controls overlaying the map,
you can now pad them in, so
they will remain visible.
And despite your other Chrome
on top of the map canvas.
ROMAN NURIK: So I guess my
two points turned into one
point I want to make, because
that was one of the points
I wanted to make.
One of the points
I wanted to make
was the background, there
will always be, like you said,
there is always some
background protection.
I think in this first iteration,
I guess there'll be a gradient.
So regardless of what's
shown-- I guess, regardless
of what your app UI
is, there will always
be a gradient, a subtle kind of
black to transparent gradient
behind both the status bar
and the navigation bar.
So just keep that
in mind if you're
designing screens like this.
And also, another thing
I wanted to mention
is we don't really have
guidance on exactly how you
should use this yet.
So this is still, I'd say,
in an exploratory phase.
One of the things that I know
one of the engineers mentioned
was that you should try to avoid
using action bars in this case.
I think that this
translucent bars type of UI
is really designed more for like
wallpapers or kind of wallpaper
type apps, apps that really go
full bleed with the content.
So it's not really
quite clear exactly how
you should use this yet
with other UI Chrome.
But definitely, this is just
one of our early explorations.
All right, let's move
on to launcher icons.
ADAM KOCH: All right,
so, for launcher icons,
hopefully you're
already aware, they're
normally shown at 48
dp, a square of 48 dp.
Now on Nexus 5, due
to the new launcher,
they're actually shown larger,
actually about 25% larger,
or 60 dp.
And then because Nexus
5 is an XXHDPI device,
essentially, in
order for the icons
to show at their
crispest, you really
need to include an
XXXHDPI, or 640dpi icon.
Yes, we really just said that.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM KOCH: So the actual
pixel size of that icon
is 192 pixels.
And this is somewhat similar to
how tablets behaved previously
with their launcher.
They would actually show
the icon slightly larger,
and so it needed to dip into
the density bucket that's
one larger than the density
of the actual device.
And so I guess our
guidance here is
the icon is just so important.
It's such an important
part of your application.
You should really be
including an asset that
makes it look its best on all
devices and all screen sizes.
And so that means,
in this case, you
need to provide XXXHDPI
icon for the launcher icon.
ROMAN NURIK: And so right
now, this applies to Nexus 5,
since Nexus 5 has this
new kind of launcher.
Be to imagine that other
devices in the future
would potentially do
something like this.
So basically, just
get ahead of the game.
Start including
the 640dpi icons.
And also, I mean, just
to kind of, I guess,
talk about how this works
with tablets, right.
If there was an
XXHDPI tablet, then
you'd have to do this anyway.
It just happens to be that
there's an XXHDPI phone that's
now using this tablet scaling
behavior for launcher icons.
Let's move on to new gestures.
So these aren't exactly,
I guess, new gestures,
but we're formalizing two
new gestures in our design
guidelines.
So if you go to
developer.android.com/design,
I think it's under Patterns,
Gestures, I forgot.
But you'll see two new gestures.
The first is an expansion
of double touch.
And the second is, I guess,
double touch to drag.
So the expansion on
double touch basically
says, if you're looking
at a photo, right, I mean,
or something that's just
zoom-able, double touch
to zoom it in.
If you're in something
like Google Chrome,
like that, right, exactly-- if
you're in something like Google
Chrome, or something
else that has
bits and pieces of
information laid out,
and you want to double
touch on one of those bits
and pieces of information,
basically what this is saying
is that you should zoom
in to that content.
So if you're in Chrome
and you double touch
on a column of
text on a web page,
it'll actually zoom to
fit that column of text.
So this basically says if
you have any other types of,
or if you're
building an app that
is similar in terms of
what content it presents
and the layout in which it
presents that content, this
is something that you should do.
So this may apply to things
like magazines, or books,
or things like that.
The second, and this is
a little more universally
applicable I'd say, is anytime
you have double touch to zoom,
if you double touch and
then drag up or down
with that same finger--
so it's like touch,
touch, drag up and down,
that should basically also
be a zoom.
So rather than zooming in by a
fixed amount, say, 50, or 2x,
or whatever it is, double
touch and drag up and down
is kind of like a dynamic zoom.
So I think if you drag--
I forgot if it's drag up,
it's zoom in or zoom out--
but an example of this
is Google Maps.
So if you open up
Google Maps right now--
and this has been around
for quite some time--
if you open up Google
Maps right now,
double touch, drag up and
down, I think up will zoom in,
down will zoom out.
NICK BUTCHER: It's
in Chrome as well,
and it's a great way
because you can do,
similar to a pinching gesture,
but you can do it one-handed.
So it's great.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, that's
actually how I discovered it.
I was using Maps with one
hand, and I was double
touching a lot, and then I
accidentally stumbled upon it.
I was like, oh my god, this
is the best thing ever.
But if you're building
something like this,
then definitely use this.
I will say that we don't have
sample code available just yet,
but I'll probably do an update
to our Gestures training
class for this at some point.
NICK BUTCHER: No, the gesture
detector in the Support
Library's being updated
to support this.
ROMAN NURIK:
Excellent, even better.
There you go.
NICK BUTCHER: We've
written the code for you.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome, so my
change to the training class
will be one line of code
or something like that.
Awesome, let's move on
to screen recording.
NICK BUTCHER: So this
is nothing to change
the way you have to
design your applications,
but we've made it a lot
easier to capture video
from the device.
So I think in
previous shows we've
talked about having
specialized hardware,
or certain devices which
let you record the screen
output in order to create really
high quality product videos.
But a new system
feature in Android 4.4
called Screen Recording
will let you do this
by a simple command.
So there's no on device UI
that's actually doing this.
This is like a developer
feature for producing
these videos ahead of time,
rather than a run-time user
feature, as it were.
And so you simply execute this
command written on screen,
and this will record up
to 15 seconds of video
in full high definition, the
full kind of screen resolution.
And then you can just use the
adb pull commands in order
to get that video
file off of the device
and onto your computer.
So a really easy way to
record product videos.
And as a little pro tip-- if you
go into the Settings, and then
Developer Settings
section, and enable Show
Touches, as we have
on this tablet here,
you get these white circles,
which goes really well with it.
I'm doing a screen recording.
So you can produce high
quality product videos
without having fingers
in the way, and so forth.
ROMAN NURIK: I will say, I think
we updated it to three minutes.
Or is it still 15 seconds?
I think at some point
we made a change
to make it three minutes.
But it's either three
minutes or 15 seconds.
One other thing we should--
NICK BUTCHER: Has that changed?
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: One other
thing we should mention
is that what we're doing right
here with our own setup here--
we're not using screen record.
Again, screen record is not
meant for live screencasting.
It's really for recording
video, and then post-processing,
or things like that.
So it's really good for things
like your promotional video
on Google Play.
If you want to show a
video of your app in use,
this will make it
tons, tons easier.
All right, last but not
least, scenes and transitions.
ADAM KOCH: Yes, so
scenes and transitions--
so the animation
framework in Android
gets some fantastic new
additions in Android 4.4.
And we're calling them
scenes and transitions.
So there are two parts to this.
The first is where
you can essentially
define scenes within your UI.
This is sort of two different UI
states for a particular screen.
And then you can have the
system actually calculate
the animation to get
from the first scene
to the second scene.
So this is, it's a
really neat addition.
And the second part to this is
you can actually go and modify
a particular view group.
So this is talking more
on the developer side.
A view group is a
collection of views
within a particular screen,
and make changes to those,
and have the system animate
those changes as well.
So it's definitely
something to look
into if you want to get more
involved inside the animation
side of Android.
For developers, there's the
android.transition.trans--
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: Transition manager?
ADAM KOCH: --transitionmanager,
that you should go look at
to get more
information about this.
And if you're familiar
with Keynote's "Magic Move"
animation, which let's you
morph an object from one
portion of the
screen into another,
it's very similar to that.
So just to give you an idea of
how it works or how it looks.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and I
think that the big thing here
for designers is if you're
talking to a developer
and you're like, hey, I
want these animations,
these transitions to
happen, and they're like,
oh, you know, I just
can't do that, it's
going to take too long-- for
earlier versions of Android,
it does require a bit of work.
It's definitely still doable.
But if you're running
Android 4.4 or later,
I don't think there's an excuse
anymore to not use this API.
The great thing about this
API is that it's so simple.
I mean, the easiest form of
this is one line of code.
It's basically
just, I think it's
begin-delayed-transition
or something like that.
And it basically says anytime
you show, or hide, or resize,
or move things, automatically
adjust their bounds,
or animate their bounds, or
fade them in, or fade them out--
it's really awesome.
So I think that,
for designers, make
sure that you press
your developers to use
this new API if they
have any sort of concerns
over the amount of
time it would take
to implement
certain transitions.
ADAM KOCH: And lastly, for
developers, look for a DevByte
from our animation
expert, Chet Haase,
which we live very
shortly as well.
ROMAN NURIK: So
that's it for what's
new in Android 4.4 KitKat
from a design standpoint.
Watch out for all those
DevBytes that we talked about
for developers.
And we're looking to create
a whole bunch of design bites
on these topics as well,
over the coming weeks
or months-- hopefully weeks.
So, yes, stay
tuned for all that.
Anyway, so, see you next week,
or the week after, or whatever.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you later, guys.
Adam Koch here.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye
from Nick Butcher.